The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Right?
So here we are.
See?
Because what I want you
to do is feel your oneness
with modeling using
computational quantum
mechanics and the sun's energy.
Right?
That's really what
I've been wanting
to try to bridge, the
applications of using
the sun in renewables,
and how that connects
to ways of modeling electrons.
OK?
So I really want to
get to this other topic
that we started which is
using the sun's energy
to make electricity.
OK?
So I want to cover that today
and a little bit on Thursday.
OK.
Now, since I've made
PSET 6 optional,
I wanted to just discuss a few
points from it to start with.
OK?
Because that's like closing the
loop on our modeling of solids,
and then we'll do a little
more motivation on solar PV,
and then we'll talk
about how computation
can play a role, as I said.
OK?
So actually, I'm going to
bring up the PSET here,
and I just want to--
I'm not going to do
the problems with you,
but I just want to ask
you how you might approach
these problems,
just to make sure
that, as we close this field
this simulation of solids
with quantum mechanics, we have
a sense of what you might do.
The equilibrium
lattice constant,
how would you calculate the
equilibrium lattice constant?
Somebody tell me.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Looking for the
lattice which minimizes
[INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: And
how would you look for that?
AUDIENCE: Change the
lattice [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
Yeah.
So you could just like
change the lattice right,
and I have like
lattice and the energy.
And I do like 4 and 5
and 6, or maybe that's
not a good enough grid.
Maybe I need 4.5, 5.5.
Right?
And what would my
curve look like,
if I have an energy,
energy versus lattice?
What's it going to look like?
Yeah, something like that.
I don't know, and the minimum,
the equilibrium is here.
Now, is that converse
with respect to k-points?
Well, that's
something you can do
the curve for different
numbers of k-points.
Right?
But now, what if I wanted to
calculate the binding energy,
or in a solid, we call
it the cohesive energy?
Why?
It sounds cool.
It's different.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying.
You were waiting for that.
We got a big cohesive
energy [INAUDIBLE] or no,
that didn't have
anything to do with.
Yeah.
10 seconds, do you call?
Do you call a foul with 10
seconds left in a playoff game?
That's all I want to know.
10 seconds left.
You play it out.
Right?
I don't care if it was like
the worst flagrant foul
of the year, you
let it play out.
You don't call a foul with 10
seconds left in a playoff game.
It's just not the
right way to lose.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
What's that?
You're feeling it?
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
All right.
How would you calculate
that cohesive energy,
the binding energy in a solid?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So after you find the
equilibrium lattice constant,
you have the [INAUDIBLE] energy.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
That's an energy versus
lattice constant.
AUDIENCE: Then you can make
the lattice constant really,
really, really large, and
then you'll get, basically,
so it's like an isolated
atom, get that energy,
and you've got two [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
I like that.
Did everybody see that?
Yeah.
Let's see.
If I look over here, because
you know you love the nanoHUB,
and you want to see
something on it today.
Ah!
That's because I
didn't turn on my--
wait a second.
OK.
Turn it on.
So now, if I ask
you how to converge
the k-points, Sam, for the
cohesive energy calculation,
how would you do that?
AUDIENCE: Do exactly
what I just did,
and change the
number of k-points,
and see if cohesive
energy changed.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: And is
the number of k-points that you
need going to be--
what's that going
to be for the atom?
AUDIENCE: Small, probably
really just [INAUDIBLE]
isolate that, just
not really periodic.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
If it's really
isolated, you shouldn't
need more than one
k-point for the atom,
but the solid is
where you might need
to look at the convergence.
Right?
So you see, here's our
tool, and here is--
it's actually already
defaulted to silicon.
Right?
And so you can just press--
why isn't it-- this
is just torturous.
OK, there we go, Simulate.
There's two scroll bars,
and I can't handle it.
Maybe it's me.
I don't know.
I like to blame the nanoHUB.
So this is silicon.
Right?
And I did silicon,
and I got a crystal.
And I forgot to click to
show me the structure,
but it's this
beautiful structure.
OK?
And in the output, it
gave me 214.6 eV, 214.6.
So my energy here,
let's just say
that was the right
lattice is 214.6 eV,
and now what did you say to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: The
lattice really large.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Lattice constant.
AUDIENCE: Maybe say, I
don't know, 15 or 20?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
20, let's apply it too.
20 angstroms, and
then anything else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
Except I don't really need
four k-points, but let's
just leave it in.
OK?
Is there a way to tell after
looking at the simulation
one second if I actually
should have had more--
if I choose one k-point--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
And if it's wiggly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: I should
try to converge the k-points.
Because if the band
structure is wiggly,
it means there's something
going on versus k.
So there's a dependence
on k, and if that's true,
then I shouldn't be settling
for just not testing
the convergence.
Right?
I should at least try to
increase the number of k-points
to see if [INAUDIBLE]
so here it is.
There is my crystal of silicon
with really large lattice
constants.
So you see, those atoms aren't
even trying to bond together.
Is it large enough?
How can you tell?
Well, you could look
at the bone structure.
Yeah, and what should they be?
If these are really atoms,
these are really atoms,
then the band structure--
oh, look at that.
Those are beautiful
silicon states.
Right?
These are S&P states of silicon.
It's an atom.
Because I just made
them really far apart,
so they didn't feel anything
from their neighbors.
Right?
Now, I got an energy here
of-- and I'm coming back
to your question
here in a second--
but I got an energy here of 203.
OK.
So I got an atom was 203,
and let's just round it.
I'm just going to truncate
214 and 203 is the solid.
OK?
So Sam, what do I do next?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: And the
cohesive energy is 11 eV.
And then I look it up, and I
actually see that it's 4.6.
Because I looked it up, and it's
been measured in experiments.
What did I do wrong?
The cohesive energy of
silicon, from my calculations
I did the solid minus the
atom, and I find it's 11 eV.
AUDIENCE: Making sure you've got
the right lattice [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
For the solid?
Maybe not, maybe I was
here, but I wasn't 6 eV off.
I know that, but it's
a really good point.
That's one thing to check.
What else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Did you converge
to your basis set?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Did I conversion it?
Very unlikely.
Excellent other point to check.
Probably could get me a half an
eV even, or more, maybe an eV,
but it's not getting me 6.
This is actually a really
simple problem here.
What is my cohesive energy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
divided by 2.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because
there's two [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Don't forget that.
Yeah.
See, you have a
certain number of atoms
that you made your
crystal out of that
went into the simulation.
Right?
That's actually, when I
give this problem, that's
a very common mistake.
Well, I guess I'm
giving this problem,
since it is a problem set.
So don't make that mistake.
You don't need to,
because now, you know.
When you go to the input here,
remember, this is my basis.
My basis had a certain
number of atoms in it,
and so then that's
what gets repeated.
So the number of atoms, or
electrons from those atoms,
in the simulation is for
two silicon atoms, not one.
So the cohesive energy I
calculated was per two atoms.
So if I really want the
cohesive energy per atom,
you've got to divide by 2.
Another way to get the
isolated atom would just
be to take-- a lot of people
did this last year, is
they just take this atom out.
OK?
And they change that to one,
and they give a large lattice
constant, and that's a
perfectly legitimate way.
It's the same thing, actually.
You're basically just
getting those atoms
to not see each other.
But then, you had
a cohesive energy
with two atoms in the unit
cell and an atom energy
with one atom in the unit cell.
You just got to
keep track of that.
Right?
So energy per what?
Per your basis.
OK?
Basic stuff of
simulating solids.
OK.
Any other questions?
I may come back to the PV
question in a little bit,
but I just wanted to make
sure we feel our oneness.
OK.
There was a question up here.
AUDIENCE: What is the principle
definition of cohesive energy?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: So
the cohesive energy really,
the feeling is the
gluon between the atoms.
That's the feeling definition.
It's how strongly
they're glued together.
The actual
quantitative definition
is it's the energy of the
solid minus the energy
of the constituent parts
which in this case are atoms.
But you could be looking
at say in a molecular solid
and then you might want to
know the cohesive energy
between molecules.
Right?
In which case, this would be--
and then, you've got to
be right with your ends,
and that's what I'm saying.
Right?
If you did your solid
with two, then you
need to have N times
the energy of an atom.
Or you can think of it as
just energy of all the atoms
together that made
up that solid.
Right?
So just make sure
the numbers work.
OK?
Now, that's actually
the atomization energy.
There lots of fun names for it.
Now, I ended the lecture before
the quiz with this motivation,
which I think is amazing that
the Earth's total resources
of oil, the 2
trillion we've used
and the other trillion
we want to use,
is energy you get from
the sun in two days.
I also very quickly
said, well, I'm not
going to talk about
climate change,
but I can't help myself.
I have to say a few words, just
a few words on climate change,
because it's really important.
And so I'm just going
to spend five minutes.
That's all, I promise.
OK.
So how hot are
things going to get?
Here's an article.
There's lots of
articles since here,
but this is a nice picture.
So I took this
from Time Magazine,
and there's lots of predictions.
And there's a really big range,
and that's part of the problem.
Part of the problem is also that
it's not about just warming.
That is what's happening
on average over the Earth,
but that's why we
really shouldn't
call it global warming.
We should really call
it climate change,
because the changes that
happen are very local.
Right?
They're very different in
different parts of the world.
Some places are
going to get colder.
OK?
OK, and so there's
lots of examples,
and you can see things
melting the size of Rhode
Island and lots of really
great images of what
the changes in temperature do.
Here's one I like,
because you don't always
think about the
warming in this sense.
But the changes in
climate also change
when things get eaten, like
animals that eat trees,
like this beetle.
That's a really bad
thing for this tree that
can live a few weeks either
before or later than it usually
lives, and therefore, there are
no predators around to kill it.
And already, in Canada, this
is just an enormous disaster.
So 411 million cubic feet
of trees have been killed,
and that's double the take
by all loggers in Canada.
So enormous problems can
arise from climate change,
and you've seen these
kinds of pictures.
So does anyone know
what the P stands for?
CO2 emissions, how much we're
putting out into the world.
PgC per year, what's the P?
Peta, peta, that's a lot.
How much is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Big number.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: 15th,
10 to the 15th, right?
That's a whole lot, and this
is from that fairly famous IPCC
report which is
actually a good read.
It's kind of boring,
but it's like Smil.
Right?
Has anybody read Smil's books?
You should all read--
anybody?
Nobody's even heard of him?
So Vaclav Smil has written
some wonderful books on energy.
OK?
It's a little bit dry.
I'm not saying
it's a page-turner.
It's not dialogue-driven.
It's not a novel.
It's not a romance, but
it's very interesting,
very well put
together, some of them.
Now, if you want something
a little lighter,
there's Without Hot Air.
Has anybody read
that, Without Hot Air?
Anybody heard of that?
OK.
That's free.
You can just download that off
the internet, Without Hot Air,
I think.
I'll remember the
author's name, in England.
Anyway, this is how
much CO2 we put out,
and these are just what they
did is they just said, well,
if we turn it over quickly--
you see, because the amount
of CO2 in the atmosphere
is different.
It's still going
to keep increasing,
even if we change our ways.
And so there's going to
be still an increase,
and then it's
going to come down.
This would be the CO2
in the atmosphere.
And if we turn it over a little
later, then we get the green.
And if we don't turn
anything over until the red,
we go up to 1,000 parts per
million in the atmosphere,
and that's a lot.
What does that mean?
Well, it's hard to predict.
It's very unlikely,
in my opinion,
we'll do anything
but the red, if that.
Right?
You can see these things.
It's not that hard.
You can look at the data,
and you can actually
see these are the famous
measurements from Keeling.
You can see the
seasonal breathing,
but you can also see the trends.
And you can even see where, for
example, oil production slowed.
You can actually see
it in this curve.
OK?
So it's not hard to see
anthropogenic connections
to CO2.
That's actually obvious.
I think the connection
between that and temperatures
has been debated
more, but I don't
think many people disagree
anymore that there's
a very strong correlation.
And this goes back
400,000 years,
where now I think a
million years of data--
if you look at the ice cores,
there are bubbles in the ice.
I promise, I'm almost done,
but I couldn't help myself,
because it's important.
Right?
There are bubbles
in the ice, and you
can see in the bubble
how much CO2 there was.
Right?
These things get trapped.
It's really cool.
Right?
Bubbles of air get
trapped in ice,
and they're there from
a million years ago.
And we can take them out
and do really, really
careful measurements.
And we can also get
the temperature,
because we can look at the
ratios of different isotopes
of the water at that time.
Because the ratios of the
isotopes of oxygen and hydrogen
in the water at that part
of the ice tell you how warm
the water was on average.
Right?
Fairly robust, and you can
see very strong correlations.
This is where we are here.
This is 373 from 10 years
ago, and 1,000 is very likely
to be where we'll be.
OK?
OK.
Now, so here's the thing.
OK?
I'm almost done.
This is the guy who
ran for governor.
Anybody remember him?
A couple.
I'm not taking a political side
here, but what I don't like
is when this issue
gets politicized,
which is ridiculous levels.
It does on both sides, by the
way, both sides of whatever you
want to call it, the debate.
Do you debate hard,
scientific fact?
Anyway, I can get eight
professors from MIT
on both sides of this issue,
and no one in this room
will walk away
understanding what
they said about climate change.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well, yeah.
So I'm not trying
to make a statement
about this particular
politician,
but I just want to
make this statement
to show how this gets distorted
for political purposes.
This is total nonsense.
Right?
This statement is
absolute nonsense,
and what he's talking
about is there is actually
someone at MIT who
has argued in actually
very strong ways that you
need to pay attention to
against a connection between
anthropogenic activities
and climate change.
There's one person.
Most people I think do
not fall into that camp.
But this is the way that
we tend to then just avoid
the whole problem and
not look at it anymore.
Right?
So I just think that's
detestable, detestable.
Yeah, why not?
We'll go for it, and
this is the reason.
Right?
So now, this is
on the other side.
This is on the other side.
So one side is forget about it.
Nobody at MIT even knows
what they're saying.
Right?
It's total nonsense,
and then the other side
is we're all going to die.
Right?
Now, there's a lot of--
OK.
So this is from Climate Works.
There's some actually really
good studies that have gone on.
What happens when the
temperature does go up?
Because it will.
Right?
It may take a little while, may
take longer than that, shorter
than that, but it's
going to go up.
Right?
And as I said, it's not going
up anywhere, everywhere.
It's going to go up in
some places a lot more,
and in other places,
it will go down.
OK?
And so species extinction,
storms, droughts, all this,
but whether you
believe this side
and you look into those
studies, some of which
are actually very well done
and careful, others of which
are not.
What you realize very
quickly is this is not
an experiment we want to run.
Right?
This is not an experiment
we want to run.
Right?
So that should be one of
the underlying messages that
comes across that makes us
at least, at the very least,
take this very seriously.
OK?
So I could go on, and
I won't, but I just
had to say a few things.
OK.
Now, back to solar PV.
Any questions about my
little climate change rant?
OK.
I'd be happy to talk more
about that part of the problem
as well, which I'm passionately,
obviously, interested in.
Now, OK.
So I said the motivation is that
we get a whole lot of energy--
I said 140.
That's 130, but anyway,
it's around there--
from the sun, and we don't use
much of it compared to that.
And yet, here's how we
get our energy today.
Look at that.
Solar wind, wood,
and waste that's bio
is this yellow sliver.
That's how we use our energy.
Right?
Most of it comes
from, of course,
coal, natural gas, and oil.
And yet with solar, you
wouldn't need much land.
It's actually a pretty
land-efficient technology.
OK?
So if 2% of the US
were covered with PV,
with an efficiency of 10%, you
could supply all the US energy
needs.
If 0.3% of the
land were covered,
you'd get all the electricity
needs in the US met.
0.3%, that's compared
with 40% for agriculture.
OK?
So it's not a land problem.
It's not a land problem.
OK?
Just what's in between
highways is pretty good.
Solar PV has a nice advantage
over some other renewables,
in that you can scale all
the way down, all the way up.
So that's nice, and
if you add it up,
you can just take a small
amount of land in Nevada.
They won't mind.
Right?
Who here is from Nevada?
Would you mind?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Thank you.
You see what-- but come on,
there are some things there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: There's all
kinds of-- there's arsenic life
there.
There's all kinds of amazing--
so now, if you took spots,
if you had six Nevadas that
were willing to donate
just a small amount of land
around the world,
and you put them
in places that are
sunny, like Nevada,
you get 20 terawatts,
20 terawatts.
That's more than half of what
we think will need in 2050.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
give an estimate something
like this costs.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
There you go, $50 trillion.
AUDIENCE: Is that just
[INAUDIBLE] or upkeep as well?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: That's
just getting it on the ground.
All right?
Well, you got a
20 year warranty.
Yeah.
So this is the PV problem.
This is the PV
problem, and this is
why you don't see
solar installation
on the top of every
roof in town and why
we're not taking advantage
of this enormous resource.
It's too expensive, and
compared to other renewables
and compared certainly
to non-renewables,
it's way too expensive.
All other renewables,
all of the renewables,
except for like ocean thermal--
we're not going to do that--
are much less expensive
than solar PV.
OK?
So that's the problem.
Now it's not just--
you got to look at it a
little bit more carefully.
So sometimes, you see these
broadbrush statements,
but you've got to
realize that, of course,
this is the issue here
is one of grid parity.
So it's about the cost of the
electricity where you are,
and that is quite variable.
The cost per watt at
peak hours is over here,
and what you can
see is that there
are some places where
there's a lot of sun
and electricity prices are high.
We're basically
already at grid parity
up there, like those
places I used to live.
And then there are
other places where
we think that by
within 10 years we
may reach grid parity in
a whole lot more places.
So it depends, because
solar PV isn't just about--
it's not just about the
sun's average over the Earth.
It's about really where you are.
How much sun is there?
That's why you can get I think
the payback time in California
is like seven years, and here,
it's double that or something.
OK.
So that's an important
point, and so I just
want to show this, because you
see sometimes these like it
would cost $50 trillion,
so let's not do it,
or it's going to be--
or we can do it,
because it's all there.
We should just do it.
We see these big arguments.
I think it's sometimes
important to come down
to more like practical ideas.
Right?
And one way to look at this
is just what happened there?
I did not put that
into the graph.
If you look at, say, the
percentage of electricity
sold in the US at
or below some price,
and you look at-- let's
see if this works.
Yes-- and you look at just the
10% most expensive of that,
there are all kinds
of questions that
come into this argument
concerning what would happen
to these higher priced markets.
But let's just suppose
you could grab them
at their current price.
Then, the top 10%
would get you down
to $0.14, $0.14 a kilowatt hour.
That's the price target.
So the question is,
could we replace
10% of electrical energy in the
US with PV at a cost of $0.14?
That becomes the target.
Right?
Actually, now that starts
to sound reasonable,
not easy in any way,
but more reasonable
than replacing all energy
or all electricity.
One important point is it
actually could be done.
It could be deployed.
OK?
But another really
important point
is actually, if anyone says I'm
going to replace all of the US
electricity needs with
solar, ask them how they plan
to store 90% of that energy.
OK?
The grid can't take it.
The grid is not a battery.
It sort of is a little
bit, but it's not a lot.
It can't do it.
It can't handle the
storage that you
would need right now, if you
replaced everything with PV.
And in fact there's
no storage technology
right now that exists
that could handle it.
Right?
So keep that in mind, when your
friend says from say Harvard,
well, I have a plan.
I have a business strategy.
We're going to replace
everything with PV.
Ask them how they're
going to store it.
Right?
OK.
But 10% you could
squeeze in there
without inventing a
completely new battery.
OK?
Oh, yeah.
This is a side note.
We think a lot about
our developing--
I think maybe I showed this.
I don't remember.
We think a lot about the CO2
in the developed countries,
but this is really
where the problems
are going to be, is how
they choose to do things.
OK?
OK.
Now, we're going to talk
about how a solar cell works
and how computational
quantum mechanics can
impact this problem, this
problem of cost really.
And just to set the
stage, I want to be sure.
So this is what you
already know this that--
let me get back to this.
The sun, when it's
above the atmosphere--
because you had these spectra
in the second homework,
and we talked about this.
If you're up here, then
that's how much power
you get from the sun.
And if you're now
when you're down here,
then you have the atmosphere
which absorbs some of that.
Remember that causes
dips in the spectrum,
because you've got
certain molecules
in the atmosphere that
just take all the light out
of that frequency.
Right?
And then what we
tend to do, usually
when we talk about solar
PV, is we say, well,
that's actually not
what you really get.
What you really
get on average is
something like the sun
coming through at an angle.
Now, why is that important?
So this is the standard solar
PV spectrum that you use.
It's called AM1.5, Air Mass.
So you take the air
mass into account,
and it's 1.5, because
it's at 45 degrees.
Why does that matter?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's at
an angle [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Well, so definitely there's
an angular dependence.
That's absolutely right.
There is an angular
dependence of the power.
Right?
That's the cosine.
You've got a cosine function,
basically, and interdependence
of the power that the solar
cell generates with respect
to the position of the sun.
But what else is going on,
when I put the sun at an angle?
AUDIENCE: It's more [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
It's more air to go through.
Right?
So that's why very
often this is the power.
This is the average.
So there is more
air to go through,
less air to go through,
more air to go through.
Right?
And so we just have
some standards.
A lot of times, you take
AM1.5 as the standard.
It's what you use when you
buy like a solar simulator,
and you do the tests in the lab.
That what we use.
OK.
So now, we'll go through
every single curve
here and have a quiz on it.
Yeah.
No, this is actually-- so
has anybody seen this graph?
One person, two people, OK.
This is actually, if you
meet somebody in a dark alley
someday.
And you've got your
panel, your solar panel,
and you pull it out, and
they pull theirs out.
And you want to know who's
got a more efficient panel,
who decides?
Right?
NREL, that's where you take it.
You take it to NREL.
Right?
So you say, take it outside.
Take it to NREL.
NREL is the National--
Does anybody know who NREL is?
National Renewable
Energy Lab, it's over
in Colorado, not a bad state.
And they do this
very careful testing
on all kinds of
solar technologies.
One of the cool things
here about this to me
is, first of all, look at how
many materials make electricity
from the sun.
Isn't that amazing?
I get really excited about that.
Now, when you buy
a solar cell today,
there's a little
bit of variation,
but most of the time,
it's made out of what?
Silicon.
Silicon, and in
fact, look at here.
There's different kinds,
but actually, it's
really multicrystalline.
Single crystalline is
a little more efficient
but more expensive.
So most of the cells you
buy are multicrystalline.
So you can find it, and
that's these squares here.
And you can see that silicon
has gotten better with time.
The efficiency used to be there,
and it keeps on getting better.
And now, if you want to
buy silicon solar cells,
you can buy them.
I can't get 20%--
multicrystalline silicon, you
can't get that on the market
easily, but I can
get about 18% cells.
Actually, that's not true.
Multicrystalline I
can get lower cells.
So these are like the efficiency
that you could get at most,
and then there's like
what you can actually
get in your product.
Right?
And there's a big difference.
So these are like
what the record has
been in research labs,
tested and verified by NREL,
and then there's
like now I buy it.
Who can sell me it, and
what's your efficiency?
And it's always lower.
And for monocrystalline
silicon, which
is like the best you
can do, that's here,
you see that we're
pushing what I'll
show you is close to the
theoretical limit of how
efficient this can
even do this process.
But that's 27%, but
if I buy it, 18%
is the best you can get on
the market of monocrystalline.
Right?
Now, why is that?
Why is there such a difference
between the research cell
and what I can buy today?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
But then you also
have the bidding process.
You have interim [INAUDIBLE]
mass production [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Scale
up, scale up is hard.
So I can make like a
little solar cell like this
and send it off to NREL.
And they'll mark it at 28%,
and now I get $100 million
from some happy-go-lucky VC.
And I build my plant,
and all of a sudden,
there are regions like
this in the cells I make,
but most of the
cell is like 10%.
Right?
Why?
Well, manufacturability, scale
up, huge issues with solar PV,
huge issues.
OK?
There was a spin
off that I won't
name names, where it was really
exciting, because they were
literally like putting hard
drives in the toaster oven
and getting out solar cells.
And it was such a cool
idea using old material
from other processes, and
little parts of those cells
were so efficient.
It was really promising,
but with the homogeneity
was terrible.
And that's because you
need processes that can
get you uniformity at scale.
This does not tell
you about that.
Right?
Now, I love this
area down here, where
you have all kinds of
new materials happening.
So in my group, we
work on the bottom
of the barrel in efficiency,
but it's really exciting.
Because these are all
different materials, where
I think there could be
big changes in efficiency,
like materials made out
of carbon, quantum dots.
You can make solar cells
out of quantum dots.
OK?
Why would I care about those
kinds of other materials?
What might they offer me?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Let's
say, I can get them up here.
Let's say, I can get
a quantum dot cell.
Let's look at my
little legend there.
Where are my quantum
dots, the triangles?
Oh, they've only been
around since 2010.
How cool is that?
And look at that curve.
They're doing well.
If you have two points,
you can make a line.
Right?
And if you extrapolate
this, in just six years,
they're going to be as
efficient as silicon.
Why do I care?
Why do I want all
these materials?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
less expensive
or more easy to mass produce.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Exactly.
Yeah.
It's all about cost.
So new materials might
give me different ways,
especially like low temperature
solution processing is a key.
Right?
So silicon PV, you got to bake
this stuff at like 11 times.
You put it in the
oven at 1,000 Celsius.
Right?
I'm just making that up, but
it's not too far from that.
Low temperature solution
processing is much cheaper.
OK.
Now, the other thing that
you need to remember,
and I'll get to computation
in a moment, in a little bit,
but I want to finish this
overview of solar PV.
The other thing that
you have to remember
is that the cost of solar
cells is not just the material.
So it is the material,
but notice that--
so here's crystalline silicon.
Most of the solar cells
today are still made of this.
But notice the blue here
is the cost of the module.
That's like the material
and the glass stuff,
and then the green is
the installation cost.
The installation
cost is actually
more than the
material module cost.
So in solar cells,
actually, that
has become only recently
the biggest problem is
the installation costs.
Even just 10 years ago, the
module cost was twice as much
as installation.
Today, it's half as much.
OK?
So you can see
that, if I go nano,
this means a lot of things.
I can make cells that have
much cheaper materials costs,
but see they're
not very efficient.
So if I want to normalize
my cost per watt,
I got to install a
whole lot more of them.
So my green curve
is really high.
You see?
Does everybody see that?
So that's the balance.
Right?
Now, the interesting
thing is that, you see,
one of the reasons why
silicon PV is so expensive
is, why the insulation
is expensive,
is because it has to be put
on glass, and glass is heavy.
Right?
There are laws in this
country about how much
a worker can actually carry
on a roof, and that limits,
literally, that limits how
big you can make a panel.
OK?
The weight is a real
problem, and then there
are other costs
as well on they're
called balance of systems that
go into that installation cost.
But what if you
could make materials
that could be put on
templates other than glass?
Maybe then you
could really change
the installation, the
paradigm on the installation.
That's a big, big
reason why we're
interested in all of these.
Right?
So these are all thin film.
These are all thin film.
This is thick film.
Now, what can you compute
because of this class
to tell me why this is
thick, and these are thin?
Is it the band gap?
What about the band gap?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Direct or indirect?
And as a first thing, as
a first approximation,
is that band gap
direct or indirect?
indirect here, direct
here, therefore, you
can make very thin films.
You can make amorphous
silicon at a micron.
You've got to make
this at 100 microns
to absorb all the light.
If you don't make it
that thick, it just
won't absorb enough light.
Why isn't it absorbing light?
The band structure tells you.
OK?
The band structure
would also tell you,
or these electrons
states would also
tell you, that for
nanostructure PV,
you can make them as thin
as 50 to 100 nanometers
and absorb all the light.
That's how efficient they
can be at absorbing light.
OK?
So that is a really
important metric,
because if you can
make them thin,
then you can put them maybe
on different templates that
are flexible.
Maybe you don't need a
thick glass template.
The solution processing
is, obviously,
equally or more important.
Any questions?
There's another issue that
I just want to mention that
people, happy-go-lucky
PV people--
there are a lot of them--
talk about, which is just--
I should say, don't talk
about, which is just again
this scale, this
production scale.
Right?
We talk about how
we're going to get
to 81 kilowatt hours a day per
person of solar electricity.
That's from Without Hot Air,
an analysis done in that book.
That should be a target.
OK.
So but the thing
is that, you see,
if you want to meet that target,
then what you're going to need
is you're going to
need to get to like
100% of the US electricity
generated by solar PV
or close to that.
And that would require
being able to make
14,000 acres per day, and
today, we make 14 acres per day.
So this is the
kind of thing, you
got to look at these
problems as well,
when you think about
the solar PV problem.
You can't just dream up
a material and say, aha.
Right?
You got to really
ask how it's going
to fit in to the full problem.
OK?
So anything, any
new technology, has
to accelerate over the
silicon production rate,
has to be better than silicon.
Silicon is a moving
target, and it
has to retire efficiencies
and/or lower installation
costs for different reasons,
as I just mentioned.
OK.
Now, this is one
I'm going to skip,
but I put it here for you.
Because this is what I don't
want to talk about which
is the device view.
This is what you'd learn
in like a EE class.
OK?
And it's great, and
it's a really good way
to look at solar
cells, and I've got
two slides that summarize it.
Basically, a solar cell is a
diode that you shine light on.
I don't want to talk
about that picture,
happy to do so offline,
after class, whenever.
So this is the typical
kind of picture,
because this does not--
this picture does
not let me take
the viewpoint of electrons.
That's where we're coming
from in this class is, well,
what does an electron do in
this material at the scale
of the atom, and that's the
picture I want to start with.
So I'm going to go down
the level from these device
models which are
extremely useful,
and I'm going to
look at this picture.
OK?
So this is the picture.
This is what an electron,
our precious electrons,
our electrons.
We now feel that they
are ours in this class.
Do we own electrons?
Yeah?
OK.
I saw some doubt, but it's OK.
We still have Thursday.
We simulate electrons, and
that's what we've been doing.
This whole part of
the class how can you
model the behavior of electrons,
and in particular, what
are the energies of
electrons in a material?
That's really been our key goal.
OK?
And this is how an
electron in that landscape
sees a solar cell.
Light shines on the material,
and an electron's just
cruising around, and
then it's like, oh man,
I just got hit by a photon.
right?
And then it's like, I
better take that energy in,
but we know that for an
electron, when it takes energy
in--
Oh, David MacKay is the guy
that wrote Without Hot Air.
OK-- when it takes that
energy in, what happens?
Let's say these are filled.
Right?
This is my Fermi energy.
It's going to jump up.
That's what electrons do,
when they take energy in.
We've talked about that.
So that's what happened, and
then, what did it leave behind?
A hole which is the
same as an electron,
but not, but it's positive.
Right?
So that's a positive charge,
and there's my negative charge.
And that's what happened when
sun shined, showned, shown,
shown on it.
And then what happens here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
It relaxes.
What does that mean?
It's not taking it easy.
AUDIENCE: You go
back down a couple.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: To where?
AUDIENCE: There.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Right here?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Can it go here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the one below it.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Here.
It can't go in
between, we know that.
So it goes here, and that
is the valence band--
no, Conduction Band Minimum,
CBM, of the material.
That's where it lands.
And so just like
in the solar field,
what I wanted you to see in that
third problem of the solar fuel
homework is that you
can excite electrons up,
but you're only going
to get out delta H.
So you lose whatever energy.
When you hold something
out in the sun,
photons of all energies from the
sun are hitting the something.
Right?
And most of them are going
to just heat, wasted heat.
Most of that sun's
energy is wasted heat,
and that's because
of this right here.
Right?
So this is just heat here.
It's just heating the
material, and then this
is the energy, or
the voltage if you
want, that you can
pull the electron out,
that conduction band.
All the other energy that
you might have had is lost.
Right?
And so why don't I just make
this really, really big,
the gap?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Because if it's too big,
if the gap is too big, then
anything less than the
gap doesn't get absorbed.
If I make it too
small, then boy,
do I waste a lot of
the sun's energy.
Right?
Then, I have almost no voltage.
There's a sweet spot, and
that's what problem three
was about in PSET 5.
Right?
Now, then the electron
has to get out.
If it's a certain
kind of solar cell,
it can actually recombine
with the hole, which we really
don't want.
See, in some materials,
like in Silicon,
the electron and the hole really
don't like each other much.
They're Facebook
friends, or I don't know.
What do you kids
call it these days?
They tweet.
No, no, because nobody tweets.
Who tweets?
Does anybody tweet?
I'm amazed by that.
I have no clue what
I'm talking about.
How many of you have
a Facebook page?
Right.
OK.
I'm just learning.
It's a learning thing for me.
Google Plus?
It's gotten better?
Has it gotten better?
Sort of.
Yeah.
OK.
So fact of the matter
is, where was I?
Anyway, they don't
like each other much.
They like each
other a little bit,
like a millielectron
volt or two of binding
between that electron
and the hole in silicon.
So basically, as soon as that
electron and hole form, and one
is in the connection
band, and the other is
in the valence band,
they're like, eh, whatever,
and they just wander off.
OK?
Now, that's a
weakly bound exciton
is another way of saying
that, or really not really
much of an exciton at
all, because there's
exciton binding.
An exciton is nothing
more than a fancy way
of saying electron hole
pair, but in some materials,
like polymer solar cells,
which I will talk about,
that's not true.
You see, in some materials,
the electron and the hole
are very strongly
attracted to each other.
They are BFF.
Did I say that right?
Best friends forever,
except it's not forever,
because you get them
apart in a solar cell.
You do get them
apart, and it's sad.
But then they go, and they do
work, and then they come back.
So it's a happy ending.
So now, when it's really
weak, like in Silicon, well,
you don't need much
to pull them away.
Right?
You've got to pull them away.
You got to transport the holes
and transport the electrons
over to some metals.
And so actually, how
do you pull them away?
How do you get them out on the
right side, different sides?
AUDIENCE: Electric
field [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Yes, and yes.
Right?
A PN junction will do
it, and even there, there
can be whole regions where
there's no field really.
But as long as they finally get
to some region where there is,
and they can get off on
the right side, we're good.
OK?
But in other solar
cells, and this
is all within this picture.
This is all within
the same picture.
We can talk about
all these concepts.
So in a silicon solar
cell, recombination here
is really not a problem,
but this part is a problem.
That's really hard, because
the indirect band gap.
And then because you've
got to make it thick,
because that's bad,
this part is a problem,
because they got to transport
for a long distance.
And because they got to
transport for a long distance,
you got to make
the material pure.
So that it has good
highways to get out.
OK?
But in a plastic solar cell
or an organic solar cell,
well, these are
really strongly bound.
They really want
to be best friends.
There are half an
electron volt bound
instead of millielectron volts.
Those are strongly
bound excitons.
So a PN junction won't do it.
You can't do that, because
they're going to be together,
unless you rip them apart.
Right?
And because they're
going to be together,
what's going to happen is, if
you don't rip them apart soon,
they're just going to collapse,
and you're going to lose that.
All the photons energy,
you're just going to lose,
and the electron and
hole will recombine.
That's this recombination,
and they'll emit a photon.
Right?
That's bad.
That's a bad thing.
Right?
So in those kinds
of solar cells,
the challenges are different.
They're actually
really good at this.
Remember, I said 100
nanometers of thickness
is all you need to absorb
all the light in some
of these materials, even less.
OK?
But where there is a challenge
is how do you get them--
how do you pull them apart?
And the way you do it is
you create interfaces,
where when this electron and
hole pair get to the interface,
one of them really
sees the grass is
really greener on the other
side of that interface.
And the other one is like,
I don't like that material,
and then they split, and that's
called a type 2 heterojunction.
Which I'll show you a picture
in a sec, in a little bit,
or maybe Thursday morning.
Thursday at the
beginning of class,
I think I might have time.
So this is the level that we can
really understand solar cells
from the fundamental
electron viewpoint,
and this is the
level where you know
how to compute relevant things.
So tell me what you
can compute that's
relevant to this picture.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Fermi energy.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
OK, Fermi energy.
OK.
So that would be for the metal.
Right?
That's the level that's going to
try to line up with that level,
and you'd like it
to be pretty close.
OK?
What else?
Somebody said band gap.
Very good.
That's this.
Right?
What else?
What about the band gap?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK, direct
or indirect, very important.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Mobility which is this part.
How efficiently is
it going to do this?
Right?
Well, you can calculate that
now from the band structure.
Right?
What gives you the mobility?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Curvature of the band.
OK?
You know how to do that.
And the last thing
is that I'll just
tell you because I'm
going to show you
in a second is that when
you need to pull electrons
and holes apart from each other,
because they're really strongly
bound, you need two different
materials with a very
particular way of lining
their energy levels up.
So again, it comes back to--
there, it comes back to having
one material with levels.
This is, let's say,
the HOMO in the LUMO,
like that, and another
material, or if you
want to think about this
is the conduction band
and the valence band.
You need to have--
if you have a really
strongly bound electron hole,
there it is.
You're with me on this.
Right?
You see what I mean here.
This is a level.
That was where it was.
It's thermalized down, and
this is strongly bound.
So I got to rip them
apart, and then that
means I need another
material with levels
that come in at a very
particular way with very
particular alignment.
And that's called the
type 2 heterojunction,
and if it's not type 2, you're
not going to split them apart.
OK?
Now, how can you calculate that?
Well, you can
calculate these levels.
This is what you know how to do.
So you can actually, with
this same kind of methodology,
you can calculate the
levels across an interface.
Exactly the same
with the SIESTA tool
you have, you can look
at what those levels look
like on one side
of an interface,
and when you change
the material, what
they look like on another.
And you can tell me if
it's a type 2 interface
or say a type 1 or a broken
junction or other kinds that
wouldn't be good for PV.
OK?
OK.
So this is a very rich
picture, and really, you
can see that there
are a lot of things
you know how to
compute now that are
directly relevant to solar PV.
So let's take a closer look.
OK.
So that's what we want
to do is take a closer
look at some of these.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: What is
the [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: That's
actually the conduction band
minimum and the
valence band maximum,
and because sometimes
the conduction band
can be thought of
as a band of states.
But often, we only care
about the very lowest
one, which is where the
electron is going to wind up.
It's got plenty of
time to get there.
This thermalization process
is super fast, super fast.
OK?
OK.
So this is again what
I've been talking about,
but I'll give you a few
more specific examples.
So in crystalline
silicon which is still--
I don't know if it's 80%.
Maybe it's between 70% and 80%.
Right?
The band structure, the band
gap, and the electron hole
mobilities, this is all
something we just talked about.
OK?
And it all comes from
the band structure.
So you get the band
structure of the material,
and these properties
of the picture
we just showed fall out.
OK?
In amorphous silicon,
see amorphous silicon
is actually 3% of the market,
and actually light absorption
is really pretty good, and so
you can make them very thin.
That picture was--
where was it, there--
that's crystalline silicon.
That's a crystalline
silicon cell,
and that's an
amorphous silicon cell.
And you can see one is curving,
because you can make it really,
really thin.
OK?
Whereas, if we tried
to curve 100 microns,
it's really hard to do.
You're going to crack it.
Right?
The problem with
amorphous silicon,
so electrons and
holes also separate.
That's not a problem.
They separate easily.
They're not strongly
bound to each other,
but here, you have the
transport is the problem,
holes in particular.
Positive charges move
very, very slowly
through amorphous silicon.
OK?
So they're actually,
both electrons and holes,
are a lot slower in
amorphous silicon
than in crystalline silicon,
but holes are 200 times
slower than electrons,
200 times slower.
Right?
Whereas, in crystalline
silicon, they're
only like two or
three times slower.
So that's a big discrepancy,
and that causes big problems
and a big drop in efficiency.
Now, what you can do with the
calculations you know how to do
is you can calculate
the hole mobility,
and actually, you
can also calculate
whether the amorphous material
wants to trap a positive charge
or not.
And the way you do that is
you simply, in the code,
you simply calculate
the structure
with and without a
positive charge in it,
and you get an energy.
Right?
And then you can compare that
from one structure to another,
and try to understand something
about why this material is
trapping holes.
You see, in an amorphous
material-- do I have a picture?
I think I had a picture of--
maybe I have a picture later.
Why would we want
an amorphous silicon
over a crystalline silicon?
It's cheaper.
Why is it cheaper?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Why?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
It's just a mess.
Amorphous silicon is a mess.
Right?
It's a messy material.
Now, there are still
very important ways
of doing the processing
that can make a difference
on the performance.
Right?
Hydrogen concentration,
how you anneal it,
but it's a much easier
material to make,
since it's inherently messy.
Now, that poses
a real challenge,
because now you have a
problem that you want to fix,
the transport of charges
in a messy material,
and it's really hard to
characterize messy materials.
Right?
Beautiful problem for
computation, beautiful problem.
And we're talking about
holes and electrons,
so the only game in town
is quantum mechanics.
That's the only game in town.
Right?
You got to get to
the description
that we know how to do now of
where electrons and holes are
in the material.
And in the computer, you
can make messy this way,
messy that way, add a little
of this, put a defect in,
and you can calculate what
that does all the way down
to the scales of these
atoms and electrons.
And that would be
extremely hard,
especially in a material
that's disordered,
to do experimentally.
So this is a great
problem for computation.
I love this problem.
Amorphous silicon has a
wonderful problem called
the Stabler-Wronski effect.
Stabler-Wronski in
1977, they wrote an APL,
where they showed that you
make an amorphous silicon
solar cell.
And let's say you make it,
and you test it, and it's 10%.
And now you hold it out
under the sun for two hours,
and after that, it's 7%.
OK?
And it doesn't come back, unless
you heat it up, in which case,
it does.
What a great problem.
Right?
So you get an immediate 30%
hit on your performance, when
you have an amorphous solar
cell, amorphous silicon
solar cell, and that is a
30, 40 year problem, 30 year
problem that is unsolved.
I love problems like that.
Why?
You hold it out under the sun,
and because of the sunlight
exposure, something's--
the mess is getting
messy in a bad way.
Not all messes
are created equal.
Right?
How cool is that?
At the atomic
scale, the disorder
is different, when
you shine light on it,
and that difference,
the different disorder,
means something really
important to positive charges.
What?
Unsolved, very cool
problem, computation
can play a big role.
OK.
Now, in organic PV, as I already
mentioned, I mentioned this.
So let me get to that,
but look at this.
This is that solar
spectrum, and often we
like to plot just several ones.
So but these are just the sun,
whether you're on the Earth
or how you measure it,
but now here's the key.
This is the absorption
of a polymer
that can make an organic cell.
Now, you can see that one
issue with organic materials
is they can have really good
absorption but in a fairly
narrow range.
So I can make this
cell very thin,
and theoretically, I could get
a decent efficiency out of it.
I don't by the way, but
one would think I could.
But you can see that
I'm missing a whole lot
of the solar spectrum.
Right?
I'm missing a whole lot
of the solar spectrum,
and so that's one
issue with polymers.
Is they're very
good at absorbing,
very efficient at
absorbing light,
but usually in a fairly
narrow part of the spectrum.
So that's one challenge,
and that's something
that you now know a lot about,
because you've been integrating
this from like here back.
That was fun.
Wasn't that fun?
Yeah.
I felt the pain.
Sam, help me feel the pain.
Inform me about the pain.
OK.
Now, so that's one issue,
and you know how to do that.
You can take a polymer, put
it in your nanoHUB tool,
and integrate the
sun from its gap.
Right?
And that'll give you this
now, and you can even
do it more fancy than that.
You can even use the
density of states
to get a more realistic
estimate of how
much energy versus wavelength
that that polymer can absorb.
But another really
important problem
that comes with polymers
is that, again--
and this is exactly that
picture I just showed--
you have to have two materials.
Because in a polymer, when you
excite an electron and a hole,
they're usually strongly bound.
Right?
So that exciton is a strong
bound exciton, and therefore,
you can't split them
apart, unless you
have an interface that has
levels that align like this.
So another really important
part of polymer PV
is to design the two
kinds of materials
that will give you
those interfaces
and then control them in
some way to blend them.
It's actually a really
pretty hard problem.
There's a company, there
are several companies,
selling P3HT that is
poly-3-hexylthiophene solar
cells.
Konarka, has anybody
heard of Konarka?
You can buy them, Konarka.
A brave, bold move into
polymer solar cells
was made with $120
million by Konarka.
I would say too early, but
they're trying to push it.
Now, the problem is
efficiencies are very low still.
So you have these like they'll
give you one of their products.
It's like this size,
and it's all packed in.
And you can unfold it to
the size of this table,
because it's just
flexible and thin,
and you put it on
plastic instead of glass.
Right?
P3HD is a plastic.
It's a cheap, cheap solution
[? possible ?] plastic,
and the films only need to
be 100 nanometers thick.
So you can put it on this
flexible thing that folds up
into a wallet,
and you unfold it,
and it's the size of the table.
And you plug it into
your cell phone,
and you wait the
whole day, and you get
like two minutes of talk time.
They're very low efficiency.
OK?
But they're getting
better, and actually
the research efficiencies
of polymer cells
are now at 10%,
almost 10%, 9%, 10%.
That's pretty exciting.
Remember, research efficiencies,
what you buy is very different.
It's still very
low, 2%, maybe 3%.
That's not what they say,
but it's what people measure.
There's another
issue with polymers
though, with polymer cells.
Can anybody tell me what
they think it might be?
What is that?
Degrades, why?
Two reasons, why do
organic things degrade?
AUDIENCE: You
start pulling apart
[INAUDIBLE] from structure
[INAUDIBLE] at certain points,
it's going to become unusable.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well,
that's actually not--
you get them back, so that's
actually not the problem.
It's not that you're pulling--
It's not that you're
depleting them or anything.
It's a different problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
That is absolutely
the right answer for
3012, but in 3021-- well,
it's still-- yes, I can't ever
say no to the second law, ever.
OK?
So yes, but what else?
What happens to polymer?
There's two badnesses.
AUDIENCE: Oxidize?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
So oxygen is a tough one,
water, oxygen. Right?
Chemically they degrade.
Now, how can I prevent that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Packaging, you got it,
and what does packaging say?
What is really, really,
really good packaging
to really, really make
sure oxygen and water
doesn't get in?
That should ring this
in your mind, dollars.
That's expensive, and
that's the problem,
is now you're going back.
Well, you had solution
[? processable, ?]
cheap materials,
flexible substrates.
You're hitting it
out of the part,
and then you've got to spend
all your money on packaging.
Right?
And there's another reason
why polymers degrade.
Anybody know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
That could be
where the degradation
happens, but there's
something else that happens to
polymers, when you put them out
in the sun.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Why
did car paint used to fade?
It doesn't anymore.
You guys are too young.
Back when I was in
school, in the 1930s,
car paint used to fade.
Why?
AUDIENCE: UV radiation?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It's UV.
UV, right?
UV is tough on us.
Right?
And UV is tough
on organic matter,
and so UV will over time
degrade polymers as well.
Now, there's still lots of
discussion and debate, how much
is one, moisture, oxygen,
versus UV important here,
but both are degrading this.
Now, when you install a
solar cell in your house,
what kind of
warranty do you get?
AUDIENCE: 20 years.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
20 years, you got it.
Right?
And if it's a
Cad-Tel solar cell,
they'll offer to buy it back.
No, they'll offer to safely
dispose of the cadmium
after 20 years.
Yeah.
I'll believe that when I see it.
That's a very expensive
business plan,
but that's the kind of
warranty you get, 20 years.
And if you got stuff that's
degrading in six months, which
by the way you do, it's
just very hard to compete.
OK?
So those are some key
issues degradation.
Is not really as addressable
with these computational
quantum mechanics approaches
we've been talking about,
but I wanted to
mention it, because it
is a serious problem.
So if somebody comes
along and says,
I have this great polymer
that I think won't degrade.
We can tell them whether it
will still separate charge
and absorb light.
Right?
So we can screen some key
properties for suggestions.
OK.
Is that band gap
too high or too low?
It's pretty high.
OK?
Good.
OK.
Now, there's one other
I'll talk about today,
and then I'll finish this up.
There's not much
more I want to say,
but I'll finish this up on
Thursday at the beginning.
But another kind of cell
that is really fun--
actually in a class I taught
here to 2 1/2 years ago,
we made these in class.
We made dye sensitized cells.
Has anybody made a
dye sensitized cell?
It's really easy.
Literally, you just
take some TiO2,
and we had a contest with fruit.
We had the team
pomegranate, team raspberry,
and team blackberry, and
you mash up your fruit,
and that gives you the dye.
Right?
And that's just a light
absorber, and then
you coat TiO2, you
coat your powder.
OK?
And you put it down
on a metal, and then
you put an electrolyte
in, and I'll tell you
what's happening in a minute.
And it's such a simple, cool
fruit power, fruit power.
Right?
Solve the world's
energy problems
with blackberries which
are like $6.99 for a pint.
So that's scalable, not.
But anyway, there are
cheaper ways of getting dyes.
OK, but anyway, the
point is that it's
really simple and really elegant
and actually pretty efficient.
These are also known
as Gratzel cells,
because Gratzel was really
one of the key founders
of this idea, I think
the key founder.
And there are companies
making and selling
dye sensitized cells.
The reason they're appealing
is they are actually
even more efficient than
polymer-based cells.
They're up to I
think even 14%, 15%.
Again, the issue is packaging.
Why?
Because in this case, what
happens is the dye coats
a particle that is really good
at pulling the electrons off.
Oh, you love these pictures.
You know them now.
You feel them now.
Right?
These are the pictures we use
to describe solar technologies.
Right?
So you have the dye, where
sunlight shines on it,
and an electron gets kicked up.
Now, in this case,
you see, you're
not going to worry about
moving that electron around
in some slow polymer
or amorphous material.
You're going to put it
into a TiO2 particle
matrix, where actually electrons
zip along really efficiently.
So you really boost the
transport part of the problem.
See, TiO2 by itself wouldn't
absorb light very well,
so the dye helps you kick
the light absorption up.
So that really helps.
So the light is absorbed
here, and then the electron
transfers to the TiO2
and goes out here.
And here's the problem is you
got to get that electron back,
and the way you get
it back is you get it
back from the cathode, through
a dye, through an electrolyte--
I'm sorry, through
an electrolyte,
I just read that word.
Which is basically just shipping
electrons from this metal
electrode over to the dye.
It's just an iodine solution,
very cheap, very cheap,
but it's just an electrolyte.
Has anybody heard of or
worked with electrolytes?
Well, even if not, it's OK.
Right?
There in lots of uses, and
basically, what they are
is they're a shuttle.
It's atoms, I3's, molecules that
are carrying electrons for you
in a liquid.
What's the problem with that?
Yeah.
It's how are you going to
keep that liquid in there
for 20 years?
20 years you need a liquid
to stay perfectly liquid.
That's hard.
Right?
There's a lot of
work that's been
done on solid-state electrolytes
for other applications.
Right?
Lots of work has been done.
It's an entire field that,
if you had a good enough one,
could be used here
as well, but so far,
solid-state electrolytes do
not get you the electrons
efficiently enough.
OK?
But when you use this very
cheap liquid and very cheap dye
and very cheap nanoparticles,
you get a 14% efficient cell,
and you can do it in one hour
violating only a few codes,
safety codes, in a classroom.
OK?
So it's actually a
really cool technology.
I'll pick up here and finish
the solar PV part on Thursday.
Please, come to class, because
we will fill out evaluations
and have pizza.
OK.